Wow hey it's fear pod the best youtuber
ever I have the most subscribers so
that's how it works today we got to talk
about streaming streaming fails the
thing that I love about stream fails
specifically is because it doesn't
matter if it's one frame okay one frame
you [ __ ] up it's on the internet forever
and you're gonna get [ __ ] for it now I
have never made that mistake before I
would never be that [ __ ] stupid that
I would do something dumb like
accidentally showing my porn history in
a video first one I love this video I
love this video so much it's one of my
favorite it's this [ __ ] streamer who
gets caught for using wallhack and some
other hacks as she said playing with a
hack without knowing that the stream
actually sees her using the hack and
let's just watch oh wow
okay what is that you [ __ ]
she's not actually hacking she's just so
good at the game that she can
automatically see the health bar and
through walls this is women for you they
are so good at games
they can't help that's right why did you
reload that was the issue there I think
don't man thank you very much though
welcome to the don't bring Empire my
name is Miss Q Gemini the dumpling
Empire one of my off
it really hurts for me to break down
this footage because I myself used to be
part of the dumpling Empire my favorite
Empire to be part of the dumpling Empire
where we're trying to not be a noob
we're trying to not be a new by using
more hacks the self deprecation i am
trying not to be a noob even though i am
kind of good at this game how a
dishonest can you be collecting
donations from people simultaneously
just [ __ ] cheating up the game it's
so annoying to me when people cheat in
games because okay okay you know what
I'll take that back I sort of respect
cheating in games if you just want to
[ __ ] people over you know want to upset
them piss them off I can sort of
understand that but when you just cheat
to pretend that you're good that's just
[ __ ] stupid no that's just cringy man
I can't I can't stand beside the
dumpling army any longer for that but my
favourite bit is when she realized she
got caught and she tries to blame it
look at her face Oh
yo you guys some you do you guys ever
get that uh that weird glitch in see you
know do you guys ever get that good
weird glitch in csgo where you see
through the walls for two [ __ ] rounds
and then don't acknowledge it but then
all the sudden your oh it shows me what
spray it must have been some sort of
computer virus that install itself and
then you just didn't see it yes that is
weird wait what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
okay well what's the excuse number two
please tell me Clara Clara [ __ ] Clara
I've been telling you guys about her for
so long
[ __ ] Clara cannot be trusted what
does she do hold on
Clara give me one second alright where
is this how do I close this you'll rock
I need some help because I don't know
what I'm looking at right now what the
[ __ ] is that
hello I need to text my friend Clara
right now she was at my house earlier
today what the actual [ __ ]
I love the top comment under this video
Clara sorry yo rock do you remember do
you remember when [ __ ] Clara I got
the [ __ ] back man I'm gonna kill this
girl she promised me she didn't use it
on
[ __ ] done she was here today and I
was watching her why the [ __ ] why the
[ __ ] this is what happens when you let
people use your PC mean to Clara this
[ __ ] girl oh my god so one of my
nightmares with dreaming is that you
would accidentally leave the stream on
and then you do something horrible
something you're not supposed to do
something not Christian and everyone
sees it but this girl clearly fakes that
that's the case and it's so [ __ ]
obvious when you look it look at it yeah
yeah I think this is it I am going to go
away now I am going to go away I am
going to have a nice sleepy and nothing
else I will go and sleep no not
continued streaming nation and no
masturbating yeah
wait I just realized this video got
age-restricted so that means if I show
what's about to happen my video will be
H restricted and [ __ ] that you can look
it up yourself she comes back she plays
her fiddle ok but it's not only the
women of course we get this is also a
classic this one didn't get a true
stricted though I'd say it's just funny
when he when when guys does it what is
up everyone hello hello and welcome all
the cameras on but it bit make you the
Seinfeld all the cameras how long have
you watching did you see all of that
but you know streaming isn't that bad
it's not like actually bad things happen
wait home invasions caught on twit what
what do people live Jesus Christ oh my
god I'm joking I hope she's okay I think
she is I she made a video about it
afterwards at the time I didn't know
what was going on they were supposed to
go to someone else like their target
they were probably after a youtuber they
make more money grab a gun right now
that was actually really close and now a
car speeds off a car just sped off I
think my neighbors just got driven but
you know to me let me go check actually
hold on I might need to grab a gun just
in case but I think it's just a drive
this this clip kind of annoys me maybe
because I don't I don't know exactly
what is happening but there's some
drive-by II hear some gunshots and he's
like let me just get my knife let me
just get my gun has this never not heard
of swatting okay police comes in and you
have a gun you're gonna get [ __ ] shot
that seems like a terrible idea to have
a gun next to you when you [ __ ]
stream this is I right am I the only one
thinking like this so there's this audio
clip that sounds exactly like someone is
knocking on your door if you have
headphones on it will trick you 100% so
he knocks here and then you obviously do
this and you look there and then it goes
in this here a little less so it really
sounds like something is coming from
there like it sounds super real and some
people send these two streamers and it
tricks them okay and the reaction is
just [ __ ] hilarious
it sounds real good and then they'd be
[ __ ] high but never this stick guy
describes a gun in his truck if I had a
gun next to me I'm throwing the [ __ ]
away I'm like I'm not that's not mine
look out Kashyap what does everyone just
have guns
[ __ ] man do you want to get shot I don't
get it man lucky day he said a gun next
to him
dude you're destroyed man you can't do
that with a [ __ ] huh I don't know why
it bothers me did you not see what
happened to this dude at 11:07 on your
side exclusive a shop between the axis
and I mistaken police response it's an
alarming new crime trend in our area
Jesus Christ man why do I have to tell
people to do it right oh my god this
[ __ ] thing okay let's finish with
this one this is probably one of my
favorites so this dreamer I think the
context here is that she was playing
Dark Souls which you can tell here by
the giant window of gameplay and she was
getting drunk but for some reason and I
can't what I want to know why cuz I
don't understand why she decided to
stream herself walking up the stairs in
crutches nothing here's the thing about
that that I don't understand first of
all seeing a girl walking up the stairs
it's not that attractive okay
it's not like I'm always like oh my
[ __ ] god I can see a little better
angle of that ass like it's not that
great okay
I understand the whole thing that they
figured out that they can do on Twitch
where they like have a whiteboard and
they I can sort of understand that but
just walking up the stairs that is not
attractive okay it's not sexy but the
thing is so this doesn't walk up stairs
she walk up the stairs and [ __ ]
crunches that's like it's not sexy you
look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you
doing why she do
if I came into the stream now I'd be
like it's not a girl in special needs
like what's wrong with her is she trying
to show what a struggle it is to walk up
the stairs when a badass a handicap is
that what this is about how do how does
the thought go I'm gonna put a camera
here so that people live can watch me
walk up the stairs in crutches now how
does that make any sense I don't
understand I'm so confused but then he
keeps going because her boyfriend soda
pop and bless his soul it's this fake it
feels like I'm watching a Big Brother
reality show or some [ __ ] but I'm well
entertained so I hope it I hope it it he
comes in super pissed about this
[Music]
how was I supposed to know that well I
hope they worked it through I hope they
got through whatever the [ __ ] that was
that can't be fun to have life but
anyway that's just some of my favorite
streaming moments I had plenty of more
but I think we're out of time we're not
really out of time but we hit the
10-minute mark so you know it's time for
me to go and [ __ ] off and play some Pub
G anyway thank you guys for watching
leave a like and sister fish Stern and
all that [ __ ] I'll see you tomorrow with
another video
sister Pfister